the wheels of the British economy are
turning but not fast enough
the country's economic output
unexpectedly flatlined in February why
ask people like this rivet manufacturer
in the Midlands and you'll hear many
reasons
the inflation Spike that we've all had
to deal with which has been challenging
to say the least we've then got our
Energy bill has now gone up from 5 000
pounds a month to 16 000 pounds a month
and all of the government support has
gone for that now everybody who's on a
low wage which is great they've all had
an increase of nine percent
but unfortunately companies have to pay
for it
the cause for that wheat growth strikes
which are now leaving a noticeable dent
in Britain's gross domestic product
for Harriet a teacher who's been on
strike recently the struggle is still
ongoing the cost of living
and nine eight and three and the cost of
child care the cost of after school club
the cost of food warmth and clothing
it's all went up and it's been an awful
experience to have to
to have to struggle in Washington for
the international monetary fund spring
meetings the chancellor seemed to show
little flexibility the one thing we
won't do because it would be a terrible
mistake is to agree to an inflationary
pay rise that means that we're still
talking about inflation in a year's time
if we stick to the plan we'll bring
inflation down to below three percent
this year and then we'll put these
pressures behind us and I think that's
what the British people want the
government to do
six months ago quasi quatane came out of
those doors and was forced to fly home
to be fired Jeremy Hunt by contrast had
a much warmer welcome but the problem is
they think that while pretty much every
major economy in the world faces the
same issues weak growth High inflation
high debt in the UK they are
particularly bad
still the UK's challenges pale in
comparison with the stuff they're really
worried about here countries facing
starvation and climate disasters Nations
pulling back from each other and perhaps
even a new Cold War the world is
becoming more fragile at Conway Sky News
in Washington